Nicky: My name's Nicky Clayton
and I'm professor of comparative cognition at the University of Cambridge in the Psychology department.
I'm also a scientist in residence at Rambert, the dance company in London.
Speaker 2: Rambert?
Nicky: Rambert, yeah.
Speaker 2: What is that?
Nicky: It's the name, r-a-m-b-e-r, it was called Ballet Rambert, originally
and then it became Rambert Dance Company And most recently,
they changed the name again to just Rambert because it stands as an orchestra, and it's 90 years old this year.
We've just celebrated our 90th birthday.
Speaker 2: Okay, really, but you're a scientist in residence at a ballet company?
Nicky: That's correct, yes. Well, ballet and contemporary dance, yes.
Speaker 2: Why do they need a scientist? [LAUGH]
Speaker 2: What's science do-
Nicky: Well, I do various things but mainly I collaborate with Mark Baldwin, who's a world famous choreographer
and artistic director of the company.
And we've worked on five choreographic works together, one about evolution called The Comedy of Change.
One that was about crows and children and the power of play, called Sudden for Secret, Ever to be Told.
One about sexual conflict, which was called What Was Ecstasy.
So that's three of them,
and most recent one that we’re doing which will premier shortly in July in fact called the creation based on Hayden's
creation. It’s about the origin of life and the origin of time. It’s very movement based.
So that's some of the sorts of things that I do with my company
and I also work with some of our dancers on their individual choreography.
Speaker 2: Okay, so what's, why the emphasis on the signs or the event?
Nicky: It's the integration of the two. It's about using ideas from science to inspire new choreographic works.
So it's quite an interesting thing to do.
And Clive Wilkins with whom I collaborate on the captured thought and dance tango.
We wrote a paper together with another of my colleagues, Kevin Layland on the evolution of dance,
which was published quite recently in Current Biology. So, all the work is interrelated.
It is about, I suppose I am a movement junkie. I love to move.
I love to dance and my science and art is really inspired by my love of dance and my love of birds,
cuz I always wanted to be a bird. I've always wanted to fly and I have invisible wings.
Speaker 2: I can see them. [LAUGH]
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Let me go back to your professor at Cambridge University.
Can you tell me what this exactly is, your Department. What do you teach?
Nicky: Well, I'm based in a department of psychology these days, although my training, initially, was in zoology.
So I read zoology at Oxford University.
But I've always been interested in the interface between biology
and psychology because I'm interested in how birds think.
So the zoological aspect of it, is because of the birds,
and the psychological aspect of it is that I'm interested in cognition.
I'm interested in what's it like to think without words, as well as what it's like to think with words,
which is something I explore scientifically in terms of the ability of birds in general,
and members of the crow family in particular. They're at cognitive abilities, their problem solving.
Speaker 2: Really, it's racing comes from zoology? [CROSSTALK] The other part from psychology.
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: And you combine it with trying to find out how birds can think.
Nicky: Well, crows in particular, because crows are extremely intelligent. They've got huge brains for their body size.
In fact, relative to body size their brains are as large as those of chimpanzees.
And we know that they are extremely good problem solvers.
The kinds of things that I've been investigating are whether these birds are capable of remembering the past
and thinking about the future.
So in other words, can they, lIke us, mentally travel backwards
and forwards in time to remember specific past episodes and to imagine and crucially plan for future scenarios.
Speaker 2: Okay, let me go back to define first what, in your opinion is and then, without thinking about birth,
what do you think is thinking?
Nicky: I would define cognition as the ability to problem solve.
And it involves a series of skills, but the kinds of things that I want to include would be mental time travel
and theory of mind. These two skills are related, so mental time travel is about being able to think about other times.
So, times other than the here, and now, hence past, and future.
And, theory of mind is the ability to think about other minds.
So, if I have theory of mind, then I can understand that, your perspective will be similar to mine, in some regards,
but in other ways, it will be crucially different.
And the idea that I could put myself in your shoes, and imagine what you're thinking would be theory of mind.
I think they're two important thinking skills.
Speaker 2: They're thinking skills, but when you define what is thinking, what is thinking?
Nicky: Well, as I've said, I think it's problem solving.
Speaker 2: It's problem solving, and so what is a thought?
Nicky: So, a thought is the ability to project the mind.
So the problem with just defining it as problem solving is that I could say one problem I've got here is I'm thirsty.
I want to pick up this cup to drink the water.
Now, you could say that the ability to hold the cup and do this allows me to solve the problem of being thirsty.
Well, that's a physical task.
But the point about thinking is that you can play multiple scenarios in the mind without actually executing the task
first. So I might have never encountered this kind of object before.
Be able to think through in the mind's eye without taking any action what is the minimal amount of things I need to do
in order to drink the water. So, for example with the birds.
We have a water test that involves something similar to this.
We call it the Aesop's Fable because it's based on the Aesop's Fable of The Thirsty Crow and The Pitcher.
And in the fable of course, the crow encounters a pitcher of water.
The water is too low, and so it's not within beak reach.
And what the crow does is, she finds some stones
and puts the stone into the pitcher to raise the water level to a level at which she can drink.
So we can do something similar with our birds. We can present them with a tube that's got some water in.
The water level is too low for the birds just to be able to go and reach the water.
In fact, in our case, we don't make If the bird's thirsty we float a little tasty worm on top of the water.
Waxworms and wax moth larvae, as they're properly called as a zoologist,
are the Belgian truffles of the Corvidae world. They really, really love these.
And so they're then highly motivated to get these worms.
And of course the worms are hard to reach because the water level's too low.
And the birds spontaneously put stones into the water level to raise the water.
We can then use a task like that to, basic problem solving task, to ask, well,
how are the birds thinking through this problem? How can they solve these things?
So for example, we could have a series of tubes, only one of which contains water.
Maybe in another condition, the worm is floating in air, thanks to a bit of [INAUDIBLE] rather than real magic.
And in another one, the worm is resting on a solid, say sand,
and we can ask whether the birds understand that there's no point putting stones into a tube full of air
or a tube full of sand. That's not gonna change the level of the substrate.
It's only going to work with the liquid, with the water.
Similarly, we can give them the choice of different kinds of objects to put into the tube
and ask whether they understand that it's heavy ones that sink, that are actually going to displace the water.
And therefore allow the water level to rise to a level at which they can then reach the worm.
Whereas if they put hollow ones in or ones that just float, that's not going to displace the water.
So we can do various tests like that to see how they're thinking through the problem.
And that's a way of trying to get it, how they can solve these problems and what they understand about the tasks.
Speaker 2: Yeah, but now you are talking about the Corvidae family.
Nicky: I'm talking about how the jays and rooks and [CROSSTALK] children.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'll talk about that later.
Nicky: Yeah but that's as an example. You asked me. There isn't a set definition up here.
I can't give you full words that nails down what thinking is, because if I try and do that,
there's going to be too many caveats to it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I understand. That's why I wanted you to think out loud, what it could possibly be.
Nicky: So that's why I think problem solving, but one in which you can have sort of internal trial and error
and think through a problem is key.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, that's interesting for me.
First I would like to try to find out well, what's the area we are talking about?
And after that I would like to talk with you about how do you do your research with crows and with children?
Nicky: Yeah, so I think one difference you see-
Speaker 2: Not everything about thinking and cognition is very clear to me because our audience is well educated,
but they are not scientists. So that's why we're talking a little bit about what are we talking about.
Nicky: Yes, well, the reason I gave problem solving is that
but there are simple ways of problem solving that you wouldn't call thinking.
Would be, you could imagine you just do something through trial and error.
So you have no idea what this is, it's a novel object. And you push it this way, and that doesn't work.
And you do that, and that doesn't work.
And eventually, through exploring a number of things, you figure out that the best way to get the cup
and drink is to do that action. And then they're after you, just to more of the same.
Well, that's called learning by trial and error or instrumental conditioning is what the psychologists would call that.
And most people wouldn't want to call any problem solving that simply occurred through learning by trial and error
or instrumental conditioning cognition. They would want to say that cognition requires more than that.
It's the ability to actually think through a problem without necessarily having to learn about the outcomes first.
So that's why I've used that example as a distinction.
So what you're usually looking for is to train your animal, your human subject,
on a particular task until they're doing it.
And then you use some kind of transfer test, in which really what you're tapping into is what have they understood,
and how they do, simply more than just simple learning by rote.
Can they abstract some sort of general rule that tells you that yes, they're actually thinking about it?
They're just not automatically doing it.
Speaker 2: Why are you so interested in this subject about how this works in your mind?
Nicky: Well, I suppose I'm fascinated by thinking, per se.
And at one level, I'm really interested in the different kinds of thought processes that go on
and the extent to which they rely on words or don't rely on words.
So I say words rather than language because, of course, in humans we have language.
And sometimes we think without using words.
But I wouldn't want to say that that's without language because it's not like you take bits of the brain that are
responsible for language. And scraping them out of the brain and put on the side and carry on.
All your linguistic skills contribute to all your thought processes, with and without words.
But the whole idea that we might be able to get some to which words enrich our thoughts,
but perhaps even more intriguingly the extent to which they can constrain our thoughts, I think is a fascinating area.
Speaker 2: You meant, you expressed thinking in words?
Nicky: Thinking without words.
Speaker 2: Without words.
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: So what kinds of-
Nicky: Well-
Speaker 2: Ways of thinking are-
Nicky: Contemporary dance, visual arts, are both examples of thinking without words or thinking largely without words.
When you see a beautiful painting, it doesn't usually have words on it.
And even if it does have a word on it, like the famous this is not a pipe,
even then the point is so much more than just the words, right?
And similarly in contemporary times, you see a beautiful series of movements, but words are really secondary.
Yes, it's got a title, and yes, there might be a small description in the program, but the performance is so much more,
or the original magic effect. That is also largely without words.
I mean, the patter that goes with the effect is just a small part of the act.
The bit that everybody goes aah is when something unexpected happens,
when you realize that you can't possibly have seen what you thought you saw.
And you must have not seen what really happened. So I'm interested in those juxtapositions.
Speaker 2: A beautiful painting, you mean, the artist had a thought and he tried to express it in colors and-
Nicky: Yes, yes, and the way in which you then wonder what the artist actually saw, what they actually thought,
why they chose to represent it in that particular way.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Nicky: And even with words, I mean, I think there's an interesting difference between scientific writing
and literally artistic writing.
Because in scientific writing You want to make everything as unambiguous as possible,
because the whole point of a scientific paper is that, strictly speaking,
anybody should be able to read the method section of the paper.
And if they have the right skills and facilities, they should be able to replicate the findings.
So, in a scientific paper, you want to make everything as unambiguous and clear as possible.
But very often in literary writing, you want to make it ambiguous cuz you want layers to it.
You want the words not to be self-explanatory, but to generate new thoughts. I think that is an interesting contrast.
So, in a way, I think in really good literature,
the words are almost being used in the way notes are used by a composer to create a beautiful story.
To build rich layers of atmosphere, much of which is largely wordless, right?
I mean, you can have labels for emotions, but there's so much more to love, or joy, or sorrow,
than there is to just the label of it.
In the same way as when you see a beautiful piece of art, you hear a goodish piece of music, all these feelings
and thoughts swell up inside you, but the words are only secondary, right?
There's a subjective experience going on inside the mind of the viewer, or listener, or both.
Speaker 2: And it's a thought, you think?
Is it a thought if you see a beautiful painting, or a beautiful dance, or a beautiful- Yes, I think they're thoughts.
Nicky: Heavily charged emotional thoughts often, but- Conscious thoughts?
I think they canbe conscious, and I think they can be unconscious, right?
You can have that unconscious feeling of just, isn't this wonderful,
and then you can actually have real conscious things.
So, when you were talking earlier about the timing of the story telling,
if some sort of dramatic music comes at the wrong time and the experience, you're suddenly very conscious of it, right?
All of a sudden, skeptical thoughts come into your head where you think, mm, that's not right, or I don't believe that.
Or you see a bit of a film sequence and it's out of sync, and you go, they stuffed up there, didn't they?
And all of a sudden, those things that perhaps were beforehand just sorta punches, you were enjoying it
but not really questioning your thoughts, all of a sudden, it's like a switch, and suddenly you think, hang on a minute.
Or you're listening to, I don't know, political politicians speaking, and all of a sudden you think, you shifty nettle,
I don't believe you for one minute.
Or I can listen to the dulcet tones of Sir David Attenborough, and I find myself just believing every word he says.
Because he has that kind of a voice where if he said, Nicki, darling, please jump off a cliff right now
and commit suicide, I'd be halfway there before I was even realizing it, because he's got such a persuasive voice.
So you have that constant flip-flopping, I think, between the conscious experience and the unconscious one.
I mean, a classic case to me is when Clive and I are dancing tango.
If you were to say to me afterwards, what steps did you dance, or show me that move again, I wouldn't remember,
because when we're dancing we're in flow. Which is connected together, moving as one to the music.
So I'm not thinking, he wants me to do a backward upturn now, or a gown show-up. My brain doesn't work that way.
I'm just subconsciously just connecting with Clive and just moving together as one, and synchronating to the music.
I'm not thinking about the moves.
And obviously, that's particularly the case in something like tango, where it's such a connected and improvised dance.
But even in choreographic sequences, often you will hear the rehearsal director saying to one of the dancers,
don't over think it.
Because if you put to much conscious thought, conscious cognition into the process, you will ruin the fluidity
and the naturalness of the music.
So, it was always an interesting juxtaposition there between the conscious and the unconscious thoughts.
Speaker 2: That's very, very interesting, and maybe you can talk about that a little bit later,
because I would like to know, because I just need to know, how do you do your research about thinking?
Because, our viewer doesn't know anything.
So, now, in this part, I would like to feel the surprise that your researched crows. Do you understand?
Nicky: So you mean, you'd like me to talk about an experiment that was surprising?
Speaker 2: Not that, but for our viewers, you researched our mind, about thinking,
but our viewers don't know that you researched crows.
Nicky: Crows, okay.
Speaker 2: So, well, I'll ask you how do you do your research?
Nicky: You want me to start with I work with crows.
Speaker 2: Yeah, for example, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nicky: Okay.
Nicky: So, I suppose one way to define thoughts would be that I'm interested in studying the mental lives.
And that it's mental movements, I suppose, it's what's going on in the mind that I'm interested in.
And I work mainly with humans and with crows. And you might think, well, why crows?
Surely, monkeys I could understand, but why a crow? Well, crows are extremely intelligent.
They have huge brains to the body size. They're as big as chimpanzees.
In fact, my husband is calling them feathered apes when it comes to their mental abilities,
because they're so cognitively impressive. And they're very observant and very good problem solvers.
So the way in which we do the experiments are to give them a series of problem-solving puzzles, if you like,
with a view to trying to systematically vary certain parameters, in order to try to get a handle on they're thinking,
how they're solving a particular-
Speaker 2: And do crows think?
Nicky: Definitely.
Speaker 2: How do you know? How do you know that crows think?
Nicky: Well, because we can show that they're so good at solving these problems.
They can think about the past and the future, for example. We've been able to show in.
One experiment that they are capable.
Speaker 2: Do they have memories?
Nicky: They have fantastic memories, yeah.
So, your Clark's nutcracker, which is an American Corvid that lives Yosemite high up in the mountains,
hides on average about 30,000 seeds a year.
And can remember the location of these 30,000 caches
and people have tested their memories over a periods of nine months and found no evidence of forgetting.
So, they have really remarkable memories of where they have hidden their stashes.
Speaker 2: They remember 30,000.
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: It's false.
Speaker 2: Where they.
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Put their seeds.
Nicky: Yeah, so they've got fantastic memories, and caching, the ability to hide food,
is a very interesting behavior from looking at aspects of cognition Because you can ask it how good are there memories
and you can show that if you remove the seeds, so they couldn't possibly be using smell,
they still go back to those particular places.
We've been able to show that they don't just remember where the food is hidden.
They can remember which kinds of food were hidden where and how long ago, so they can remember what happened where
and when.
We've been able to show that they can even remember which particular individuals were watching when they hid the food,
and then they'll come back later and move those foods to new hiding places.
Which the potential themes, by definition, don't know about the new hiding places.
We've shown that when it comes to social awareness,
they go to great lengths to protect their hidden food from being stolen by others.
So for example, we've been able to show that if other birds are watching, not only do they move them to new places
when the other birds have come back.
But they will also specifically hide the food in shady spots rather then well lit places,
which is much harder for the onlooker to see. And in fact the way we discovered that was we had a BBC1 film crew come.
They were filming for a series called Child of Our Time.
And the cameraman got very frustrated because Sweetie Pie, who was a very tame, beautiful scrub jay would wait
and only had food every time the cameraman had to take a toilet break.
And eventually I had to say to the cameraman look away and I'll tell you when to start recording.
And that was the only way we could film her.
And then we noticed that she was only hiding in the places in the arena that weren't well lit.
And that gave us the idea to actually test, was she specifically choosing shady places when observers were present?
And we found that, sure enough, if another bird or a human was looking, she would selectively cache in the shady spots.
And so would all the other birds we tested.
Whereas, if she was caching in private, she was happy to cache in sunny and shady spots.
We've even shown that these kind of cache protection tactics that the birds do, so moving the caches,
hiding in shady spots and so on and so forth. That they're only done by experienced birds.
Naive birds who've had no experience with stealing caches don't do it.
So it's not just a hard wired instinctive ability. More evidence that it's theory of mind.
Once you've had the experience of stealing yourself you can put yourselves in another's shoes
and go well if I was that bird I would be watching where those caches were.
And I'd come back and steal them so I better move them to new places.
But they only engage in those tactics when they themselves have been thieves. It's really quite impressive.
Speaker 2: But that sounds very interesting and you convinced me of those crows being very smart,
or of capable of thinking, of solving problems. What are you interested in?
In how crows record family things or do you, in the end, want to find out how we think?
Nicky: Both. Both.
So, I would argue in the same way as if you want to know how a computer works,
you wouldn't want to only use an Apple Mac.
You'd want to also look at how a PC works and see the similarities and differences in your types of computer.
In order to have a better understanding of how computers work.
In the same way I'm gonna to have a better understanding, I think,
about how our brains work if I look at similarities and differences between crows and people.
Because crows are very distantly related to us, we share a common ancestor with them over 300 million years ago.
Well, we as humans, we as mammals, it depends how you want to look at it, but birds
and mammals had a common ancestor over 300 million years ago.
So there's been a long time in our evolutionary history in which we've been diverging,
we've been going down different paths. And our brains and those of other mammals are layered.
So our cortex has six layers to it, whereas the bird brain doesn't have layers, it's nucleated.
So the analogy might be that a bird brain on a mammalian brain or a human brain,
they're both full of these nerve cells that are so important for thinking processes.
And my analogy would be, if I imagine cakes, the bird brain is like a fruit cake,
and the mammalian brain is like a six-layered Austrian chocolate cake, the Sachertorte.
So they're both made of cake mix, but the structure or the layout, the architecture, is actually quite different.
So that then raises interesting questions about whether those different neuro-architectures might impose different
constraints on our thinking pattern.
Speaker 2: Well, what did you learn from the crows, so far?
Nicky: Well, many things. So firstly, we've learnt that they have really sophisticated cognitive abilities.
So there are a number of things that were thought to be unique to human beings.
So at one time it was said that tool manufacture is uniquely human and then they discovered that well, no,
chimps use tools.
We've now found that all the crows that we've tested, all the different species, will happily use tools
and even make them even though they don't necessarily use tools in the wild.
So New Caledonian crows rely heavily on tools to find food in the wild but mocks and jays don't but they will use
and make tools in the lab if they're given a task that requires one.
Speaker 2: Also you can stimulate the thinking process.
Nicky: Yes, so normally a rook has a very long bill,
and the kinds of foods that they eat are usually things like earthworms in the soil.
So for that you don't need a tool, you just need to insert your beak deep into the soil.
And they have bare patches around their faces, which are probably an adaptation for being able to dig the earthworms
and the other grubs that are in the soil. But for that you don't need a tool.
But, if you give them a task in the Lab where they will need a tool in order to reach the food.
They will happily use tools, make tools.
Speaker 2: Can we see them? Do you have any proof or evidence?
Nicky: I can show you some video footage of spontaneously taking a piece of wire
and bending it into a hook to retrieve a bucket that's out of it's reach.
And I can show you rooks and jays using stones and other objects to raise the water level to get worms.
Speaker 2: The Belgian Truffle?
Nicky: The Belgian Truffle. So we've got a lot of video footage
Speaker 2: Great.
Nicky: We can show you all that tomorrow and you can have copies of anything you'd like.
Speaker 2: Great. So how do we as humans, our species, benefit from what you learned from crows?
Nicky: How do we benefit?
Well, I think people are fascinated by animals and a lot of people would love to go far away
and see chimpanzees in the wild, making tools and interacting. And we all love the footage.
The whole idea that these feathered apes are actually in the back garden is pretty stunning, I think,
in that you could actually watch them solving problems in action.
And it's not just tool use, that was one thing that was viewed as uniquely human. We now know it's not.
And why is that interesting?
Well, it's one of a number of things that we thought was, perhaps,
responsible for how we've come to get our sophisticated cognitive abilities.
But, if these birds have it too then we are not unique.
So either that means that a lot more animals out there have it than we thought
or it means that only a select few have it
and in which case probably these abilities have evolved in very different animals with very different brains,
but probably for a similar reason. That raises a question of what is that similar reason.
Is it because of needing to be innovative problem solvers and therefore to be able to make tours if we need them,
or is it because of complex social lives?
The fact that we form long term relationships with others that we are very good at being able to detect who's honest,
and who's cheating.
We're able to form alliances and political maneuvers to strengthen our own chance of overcoming our enemies.
Politics is a good example of that.
We know that the chimpanzees form complex relationships, alliances and can do these kind of primate politics.
More recently we discovered that these corvins, these members of the crow family, like the rooks and the ravens
and the jays can do that, form these complex social relationships too. So I think it raises-
Speaker 2: Like can you give examples? The social relations were you prepared to use?
Can they fall in love, for example?
Nicky: Well, they pair for life, that's for sure. I've been very worried when one night.
I remember when two of our jackdaws, you'll like this because the jackdaws were named after ethologists.
So we have Niko Tinbergen [LAUGH] and Konrad Lorenz.
And when Konrad Lorenz died, the jackdaw Conrad Lorenz, as opposed to the human Konrad Lorenz,
Niko was absolutely devastated and just stopped eating and hardly moved for about a week.
And I was really worried we were going to lose him.
Eventually he was all right, but it looked to me like emotional devastation,
course it's very difficult to know exactly how you would say whether another bird was in love
but certainly in terms of their behavior it was consistent with being in love and then being bereft,
but they usually pair for life. So they form these very stable, long term, monogamous relationships.
Speaker 2: Is it also an evolutionary process that they pair for life?
Nicky: Well certainly in things like jackdraws it's very important if you're to defend a nest cavity
and have offspring, it takes two. And a lone jackdraw is right down the bottom of the pecking order.
So you don't want to just find a mate, produce young, and then go off and find another one when you need them.
You really need to stay as a couple.
We also know in the jays, for example, that during the breeding season the male will feed the female.
This courtship feeding is very common in a number of birds.
It's just that in the jays they do it very delicately which means that we can actually see,
and I can show you footage of this, what the male feeds the female.
So we can actually see the items being physically transferred from his beak to her beak.
So we can count what kinds of food and how many, so we can quantify the food sharing.
And what we've been able to show is is series of experiments is that the male jay is able to feed the female what she
wants even if that's quite different to what he wants.
So, for example, if I've just seen you eat a whole box of chocolates, Alex,
and then you've maybe left a couple at the end.
So I'm pretty sure you're full of chocolate, even though I like chocolate,
I could infer that you're done with the chocolates now, you're probably going to want something different to eat.
Well the jays can also do that.
They can ignore their own desire of what they want in order to cater for what their female wants.
Speaker 2: Can you say that thinking is a evolutionary process, so if it develops in the crow's mind or crow's brain,
can you say that our own thinking is developing as well? Can you develop thinking?
Nicky: Yes, I mean, you know, young children are not very good at certain aspects of thinking.
So for example,
children before the age of four don't understand what a lie is because they can't understand that your point of view
could be different from my point of view.
So there's a famous task called the Sally-Anne task which we'll demonstrate for you tomorrow that illustrates this,
where you ask a little child.
Say there's one dolly that has seen an item being hidden in one box and then that dolly goes out of the room.
And then the food is then moved from that box to a new box, the little child won't understand that Sally,
who'd left the room, doesn't know that the toy was moved here because all Sally saw was it go in the first box.
The little child, well she, Sally knows just what she knows, which is that the toy is now in this box not in that box.
And similarly, young children don't have a concept of yesterday and tomorrow.
Neither of those things, the ability to think about other minds. And to think about other times.
Those two things don't develop until children reach about the age of four.
Speaker 2: But I mean of course in people's lives, thinking develops.
But I mean for our species does the thinking develop, say in one out of 1000 years, or in a million years,
do we have developed another kind of thinking? [INAUDIBLE]
Nicky: Well, that's an interesting question, isn't it? The extent to which our thinking changes.
At one level, you could sort of say our brains haven't really changed much since beginning of humans, if you like.
And so there's probably a sense in which we're not any more intelligent now than we were.
Well I'm going to give you two alternative arguments.
Okay, so the one case would be our brains haven't changed, so probably at least since our ability to read and write,
our thinking skills haven't improved. We're probably no more or less intelligent than we were then.
The other line of argument would be to say, well I don't know whether our intelligence, per se, has changed.
But our thinking patterns may well have done.
The whole notion that we live in a digital age, what has that done to our brains?
So most people, I think don't tend to remember telephone numbers any more.
You just pick up your mobile phone and hit your search list and press the button.
We have computers and iPhones
and iPads that allow us to record information in ways which I think is fundamentally changing how we think.
I'll give you just one example in an area that I happen to know about, which of course is dance,
and in both contemporary dance and in ballet, when you develop a new choreographic work.
In the olden days, everything used to be written down through particular notation, [INAUDIBLE] notation.
And of course there was a bit of ambiguity when you come to reinterpret the story.
If you go back and look at the original [INAUDIBLE] and you want to make a new production,
as did in 2012,and you want to stick as closely to what you think was meant by the original terminology.
It's all a series of notations, which describe the basic moods, but, obviously,
there's going to be some ambiguity in what those things mean, in the same way as if you were a film maker.
And you want to develop a new version of a particular series based on book.
Of course there's the information in the book, but then there's the layers on top of that that need interpreting.
But of course these days in dance, what most choreographers do, Is to record it.
Now, you don't have that same level of interpretation, you just watch the video footage of the piece.
So that's a way in which our thinking probably has changed.
There are a lot of people, it's not my area,
but there are a lot of people obviously studying things like how Twitter and Facebook
and those forms of social media are affecting the way in which our social interactions work. So I-
Speaker 2: But can you say that if our thinking develops
and I mean in the future we will develop another way of thinking-
Nicky: Well that's really exciting question, I think.
Speaker 2: What is?
Nicky: Well the question of whether by understanding more about how we think now, we could find new ways of thinking.
So I think that's the golden nugget that It's very interesting to think with words and without words.
The work that I do with [INAUDIBLE] one of our big goals and big picture, blue skies question, is whether
and to what extent it's possible to think beyond words.
And that's why we're so interested in looking at the constraints on our cognition,
the patterns of thinking to see if that would generate new ways of thinking.
I guess it's one of the main goals of art, is to examine ideas.
So, I think one of the things we're interested in looking at constraints on our memories
and our perceptions as being the first baby steps in that direction, cuz that's a [INAUDIBLE] question.
We're not going to solve that question, but we might get a step closer to it.
So it's trying to understand why is it we miss so much of what happened and we miss so much of what we see.
Speaker 2: Is it?
Nicky: Yeah, I think that's a really interesting question.
Speaker 2: Do we miss a lot?
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Can you explain that?
Nicky: Well if we didn't, all magicians would be out of business wouldn't they?
Because the magic effect capitalizes on the fact that there are a number of things that go on in a sequence that makes
if we saw every move that the magician made in executing the fact, it wouldn't work as a magic trick.
We'd go, thanks a lot. Why are you wasting my time?
It's the fact that we know jolly well that that can't literally have vanished in thin air, and yet our eyes
and our visual cortex, our mind, is telling us that that's precisely what happened.
Speaker 2: So, it's a challenge between tricks or magic and how we think.
Nicky: Well, that's just one example.
Another example would be with memory, so that would be say tea lead should be catch,
kind of an interacting because it is probably more powerful than two of us.
But there's a phrase that we really like to use which is you do not remember what happened,
what you remember becomes what happened. So the whole idea that actually, and we all know this.
Speaker 2: Can you say that again?
Nicky: Yeah, you don't remember what happened, what you remember becomes what happened.
So, I think many people have had this experience.
You've not seen a friend for years and you reminisce about, and if you went to it, it was a very memorable event,
and it was a treasured memory for both of you.
And you start comparing notes about the event, and you realize that your memories of the event don't match totally.
Speaker 2: That's interesting.
Nicky: You have a memory that she was wearing a beautiful pair of red shoes and she says, no, no, they were black.
And she has a memory that you had a glass of champagne and you said no, no, I was drinking, I was driving,
I was just drinking coconut water. And you're like well how can this be? How can our memories.
And these are good friends, you know, we thought similarly. I'm not sharing this with an alien from another planet.
His memory's just rubbish, or her memory's just inaccurate.
You suddenly realize that there's a whole mismatch, it's how false memories work.
Speaker 2: Can you compare a thought with something unique like your eyes or your face or your.
Is it unique the way you think?
Nicky: Well I think memories are unique, yes.
I think it's very interesting that we often think of memory as being an active repository of the past. But it isn't.
Our memories are extremely subjective and they're seen through our own eyes.
So in our work with the captured thought, Clive and I talked about memories being the door to identity,
because our memories shape who we are.
And identities, our individuality shapes the way in which we choose to record
and remember those instances that then become our memories. And that's why we don't remember what actually happened.
We have a subjective take on it, we remember those bits that are of interest and relevance to us.
And quite often we can discover that there are aspects of our memory that didn't even happen at all
or happened in quite a different way.
We can do that by sharing our memories with others and discovering there are bits of my memory
and your memory of the same event that don't match.
There is a lot of research that is been done on the notion of false memory by Elizabeth Lofsters,
where she's found that,
the way which you phrase the question can bias people to remember things in quite a different way than the way it
actually happened. So you might show somebody a footage of an event.
Let's say it's a car going at 20 miles an hour or 40 miles an hour,
but actually the way in which you phrase the question afterwards that the car smashed into the lorry.
Or the car bumped into the lorry will have a much more dramatic impact on the memory that that person has of the event
than the actual speed that the car was going. False memory-
Speaker 2: Memories, yeah.
Nicky: Yes, memory.
Speaker 2: Yeah, does it mean that the way we remember. You said that determines our identity.
Nicky: That's right.
Speaker 2: So it's very personal the way you think.
Nicky: Yeah, yeah. Memories are subjective experiences.
Speaker 2: So there are no two memories alike from different persons.
Nicky: Well I think that they're all different.
Even if it's with a loved one with whom you're very close and feel that you think in the same way.
Your memories are still going to be slightly different because they're seen through a different set of eyes.
And they're being filtered through a different mind, because everybody's experiences are different from one another.
So I think even two identical twins would still have slightly different memories.
Speaker 2: Well, that's interesting. I never looked at it like that.
I thought, well, if you have been at the same occasion, then you must remember same things.
Nicky: Yeah, yeah but, we put our own subjective stamp on it.
And, that's, I think, where integrating science
and the arts just to do these kinds of questions becomes so important and, so insightful.
Because, it's easy, as a scientist just to think very objectively,
and go these are the things that have been remembered. Here's a list of things that happened in this event.
It happened in this particular room at this time of day on a particular date.
She was wearing this, he was wearing that. But that's not how our memories work. They're not just the series of labels.
Speaker 2: And a series of facts.
Nicky: A series of facts.
It's about the emotional experience and that's the difference perhaps between,
that's one aspect of why I would call it a thought.
A series of facts or labels could be extremely objective but your thoughts are personal and they're subjective
and sometimes they can change depending on how you're feeling on a particular day.
So you may revisit a memory and in consequence of which you actually change it.
You don't just revisit it and go down the list of things that happened
but all of a sudden because of something else you've discovered in the interim
or because of a different mood that you're in or well-being, you reshape it.
Speaker 2: So can you say that the factual memory or the fact you remember are objective?
But because who you are and because there's time that it gets filtered through your mind, gets subjective.
And then that's how a thought is created?
Nicky: Well sort of. I think it's a bit more complex than that.
Speaker 2: More complex?
Nicky: Yeah, well I think that there are factual labels that we remember with precision.
London's the capital of England. No idea how I know that information.
I don't have a memory of how I learned the information. But it's just something I know. And that's not going to change.
I'm not going to revisit my knowledge that the fact that London is the capital of England, that's not going to change.
But much of our memories are not purely factually based. They have all these other components to them.
And the difference there I think arises A, because we've each got a unique pair of eyes
and a unique mind that's filtering all those things as you've said.
But I think it's also because we're selective in our attention. So we also don't see everything that's going on.
And, therefore, for another reason why we might have different memories of the event,
quite aside from with our different eyes, and different minds, is that, my viewpoint of what I see,
is different to your viewpoint of what you see.
So, we can both be looking at the bird, and I know that when you're looking at the bird,
there's stuff behind me that you're going to see.
And similarly you know that when I'm looking at the bird, I can see Clive,
and I can see the background wall over there, which is not something that you can see at the moment,
because you're looking at the bird, and you're looking at me.
So, that's the selective attention difference, as well as a filtering difference. So, that's what I meant.
Does that make sense?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think I understand.
Surely When you try to research crowds or children, how hard is it to, try to, understand alien brains?
Nicky: Yes well it's.
Speaker 2: Is it alien?
Nicky: Well, I suppose it depends on your point of view.
I've spent so many years trying to think about what its like to be a bird that, for me, it's not very alien at all.
But at another level, of course, it's alien.
Because however hard I try to imagine what it's like to be a crow, I'm not a crow and I never will be sadly.
And however much I think about how children might be thinking it's a long time, sadly, since I was a child.
And even when I was a child, I wasn't the same as the children I'm investigating.
Because we've all these individual, subjective differences we've been talking about.
So, all you can do scientifically, I think, is to present various kinds of problem
and ask how the subjects be them crows or children or adult humans are solving the task.
That's what you're trying to do.
You're trying to look at what the constraints on the thinking are, what the milestones are,
and how much individual differences there are in what those milestones are both within children and within the crows.
Speaker 2: What exactly are you looking for?
Nicky: I don't know what you mean by that.
Speaker 2: Well, somehow you feel the need to research this, find out how thinking works
and somehow try to find a kind of secret, cuz we don't know and you want to find out.
Nicky: That's right. I'm interested in knowing what the constraints are on our thinking processes. And thinking about-
Speaker 2: But is there a reason why you do this?
Nicky: Well, I've always wanted to know what it's like to think like a bird.
That's for sure, but I'm also interested in knowing whether there are new ways of thinking that we are not aware of.
But by understanding better what some of these constraints are on our thinking processes that might give us clues into
what these new ways of thinking might be. And, that's where the work that I do with Clive on the couch of thought.
That's where that is so critical because by bringing in these different perspectives
and trying to understand more about what those fundamental features are,
that might help us better understand how we could improve our thinking skills
or thinking new ways that we're not aware of at the moment.
Speaker 2: Are you able to think in different ways?
Nicky: Yes, I think so. I mean, I think-
Speaker 2: So you can think in words?
Nicky: I think most of us can think without words as well.
As I said to you before, when Clive and I were dancing tango together I am not.
Speaker 2: But, I try to understand because if I think what I probably thinking works
but I never had a thought about it. So, I try to be aware of the ways I can think.
Nicky: Okay, well.
Speaker 2: Our viewers can think.
Nicky: Yeah, well, let me try to think of an example then of something more simple. Do you like wine?
Speaker 2: Mm-hm.
Nicky: Imagine I've just poured you a glass of wine. You take a sip of it.
It's really nice, it's the nicest wine you can ever remember tasting.
If you have this gorgeous experience,
words aren't really going to describe for you that experience of the taste of that exquisite wine..
We use artificial words [INAUDIBLE] We say this one's got lots of cherries and black currant
but it's a glass of wine and it's made from grape juice. There aren't any cherries or blackcurrants really in there.
There are only labels that we're trying to attach to these things to share our experiences of this thing that's really
an experience. It's not and the words are only a rough approximation of the way of sharing the experiences.
So that's the kind of thing that I suppose I mean.
And somehow just putting words on it in the same way as with the tango.
Just saying well Clive led me into a backward arch sort of thing.
It doesn't describe the exquisite experience of dancing tango.
It’s just a label for whether I've put my feet forward or backwards, but it doesn't really capture.
It captures the tiniest little aspect of that.
Speaker 2: So, words fall short.
Nicky: Words fall short, yeah.
Speaker 2: For thinking.
Nicky: For thinking.
Speaker 2: I never looked at it like that.
Speaker 2: Is it possible not to think?
Nicky: Yes, when you're dead. [LAUGH] I think it's pretty impossible not to think when you're alive though.
Whether you're aware of the sorts is another matter.
So, there are very interesting cases of people who don't necessarily have conscious access to their thoughts.
Classic case of that would be an amnesic with severe memory loss who doesn't have access to.
They've witnessed the event, but somehow the events haven't been,
they don't have conscious access to what happened at all, or patients with blind sight who can see
but they're not aware that they can see.
So, if you ask them did you see that, they say no, no, I haven't seen anything, I'm blind.
But then if you say just guess, they're highly accurate.
So their eyes have seen it but their brain hasn't registered the information that they're actually seeing it.
Speaker 2: Have you ever considered the thought that when you die, that the only thing that survives are your thoughts?
Nicky: No.
Speaker 2: To come up with it, because you say well you stop thinking when you're dead,
but maybe then only your body dies.
Speaker 2: Do you understand what I mean?
Nicky: Yeah, but where would those thoughts go?
Speaker 2: I don't know. [LAUGH]
Speaker 2: I'm trying to think out loud because just-
Nicky: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Maybe that would be interesting because it's hard not to think.
Speaker 3: The thoughts do carry on in actual fact, because they carried on within culture and within society,
aren't they? [CROSSTALK] Music by Beethoven for example.
Speaker 2: It's a bit hard to, if you answer the questions and we cannot film you, you understand? [CROSSTALK]
Speaker 2: I'm just adding something to your question.
Nicky: Yeah. [CROSSTALK]
Speaker 2: That's why I didn't listen too well.
Speaker 3: Maybe you can- I was only prompting you to ask the next question,
which was that the thoughts of one person don't necessarily die when they die,
if those ideas are culturally relevant- [CROSSTALK] transferred to their
Speaker 2: Okay.
Nicky: Thank you, Donald, it's good, yeah.
Speaker 2: That's a good, so, I suppose that's. [INAUDIBLE]
Nicky: I suppose that's where memory as a shared experience comes in. That although the-
Speaker 2: So, where does it come in?
Nicky: Memory as a shared experience comes in.
The whole idea is that although your thoughts and your memories are individual, they're personal and subjective to you,
you can nonetheless share them with others.
And in multiple ways, right, you can share them by discussing with one another, like we're doing here.
You can share them by creating something exquisite, like a Beethoven symphony,
that lives on long after Beethoven himself.
Or a beautiful piece of literature that the author dies, but nonetheless,
all the thoughts as represented in the novel remain. So in all those ways their thoughts can live on.
Although of course, there's a sense in which they live on and a sense in which they die.
Because the subjective experience of the originator of the thought, those thoughts have died.
But the shared experience of the thoughts, in the way in which those thoughts interpreted by others, live on.
And I suppose that's what history does, isn't it? You have these ideas that are recorded.
But actually as others revisit the history, just as a memory is changed when it's revisited, so is history,
so are the thoughts. So there's a level at which they live on, but they don't, they are changed.
Speaker 2: But they also get richer somehow, because now we know this music and this music and this music,
and still we manage to make new music which is beautiful.
Nicky: Yeah, yeah, and the way in which it's interpreted will change, because of the new technologies,
because of the new experiences.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Nicky: So, in a way these thoughts
and these memories are much more than just this little snippet of factual accurate information about the past.
They infuse and purveyed our history and our culture.
Speaker 2: Good and bad.
Nicky: Good and bad, and our evolution, if you like, as a species.
Speaker 2: So why do you want to fly? [LAUGH]
Nicky: I don't know how to put that into words really. I've always been,
Nicky: Fascinated by what it's like to be at the,
I've always been fascinated with being able to move in a three dimensional world instead of being stuck on terra firma.
Nicky: It's just, it feels like it's a fundamental feature of me. And yet, somehow I have difficulty verbalizing it.
Perhaps, because the kind of subjective experiences and thoughts associated with wanting to fly
and wanting to be a bird are largely wordless.
Speaker 2: So what is it, is it onwards? Is it onward?
Nicky: Thoughts, we're just thoughts, yeah.
Speaker 2: But somehow, there has to be original view as a child thinking, I would like to fly.
Nicky: I suppose it's the freedom, isn't it?
The whole idea of being able to explore the world from up above, to be in the sky and look down and see more
and see further.
Nicky: And just see that you could have a totally different perspective on how the world looks.
Speaker 2: You still have this wish?
Nicky: Yeah, yeah, yeah, very much so.
Nicky: But somehow I didn't have words that really do it justice.
Speaker 2: Is this a wish you have all your life?
Nicky: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 2: And, how do you keep this alive? But do you keep these alive, or do you need this idea to keep on going?
Nicky: [LAUGH] I don't think about it like that, it's just part of me.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, I don't think of flying like a bird. So, there's something inside you, which,
Nicky: Well I suppose we all have our spirituality, don't we?
We all have those things that we identify as being sort of core features of ourselves.
And the different people are different things, but.
Speaker 2: Mm-hm.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so when we go tomorrow, to this lab.
Nicky: Yep.
Speaker 2: We will see a lot of children?
Speaker 2: Or is that tomorrow?
Nicky: Yeah, we're doing children tomorrow and the day after, I believe. Elsa's got a little program.
Speaker 2: So what do you hope to find out with these deaths or procedures or with children?
Nicky: Let's talk about that when we do though, cuz there's lot of different ones.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Nicky: So I'd rather kind of do it with the tests there, cuz otherwise it's gonna be a bit jumbled and jarbled,
I think.
Speaker 2: Yeah,so when you dance, you dance everywhere?
Nicky: What do you mean?
Speaker 2: Well, did you dance outside, or at home, or at a lab, or at a club?
This dancing, you mean, this Tango dancing? Where do you do that?
Nicky: We go to Melongas, which are dance halls, that's the main place you do tango.
And we do them in our talks and performances.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Nicky: I guess sometime we dance at home.
Speaker 2: The last question is, why the tango because you're both not from Argentina?
Nicky: Gosh I don't know how to answer that. It's the poetry of movement, I think, tango.
It's such a beautiful dance because it's, you're so connected with your partner. They talk about it as being four legs.
An animal with four legs and two beating hearts, cuz you're so connected. So there's many forms of dance that I love.
I like ballet and salsa's great fun,
but there's something very powerful about tango because of the connection you have with your partner, so the leader
and the follower, and the way in which you respond as one to the music. I think it's very, very special.
Speaker 2: Does every scientist have this artist inside?
Nicky: Sorry, does every?
Speaker 2: Does every scientist have an artist inside?
Nicky: I don't know.
Nicky: It's not very common is it to be a scientist and be an artist in residence somewhere. And equally, of course.
Speaker 2: The other way around.
Nicky: There's artists in residence in the psychology department.
So I think we've got something there that is quite unique.
You do hear of artists in residence, but typically, they're short term residences of three months of most the year.
And usually it's the artist comes in to a place, talks to people and then creates a piece of art.
Where as I think that for captured thought what Clive and I do is truly collaborative.
It's not Clive comes and has a cup of coffee with me and then creates something.
I have a chat with Clive and we go off and do an experiment. And occasionally we meet up and talk about them.
I mean the whole project that we're doing is interwoven together.
So all our talks are written jointly and performed jointly.
And you might think of it as being 50% Nicki and 50% Clive, but really it's more like two percent Nicki
and two percent Clive and 96% licking Clive integrated
and two percent I'm only saying because obviously one voice is speaking while the other is silent and then vice versa.
But all the thoughts and all the ideas are, have collaborative mixture, and I hope
and I think that as a result it's like a Gestalt phenomenon that we are being able to share more
and do more than either of us could do alone.
I certainly feel that I wouldn't have got so nearly so far in my thinking about things if it hadn't been for Clive
and I collaborating. And it's not just an odd discussion here and there.
It really is this integrated, interwoven working together and thinking together.
And trying to make new connections between disparate sources, that alone I wouldn't have thought of.
But together, with Clive, we can kind of push each other to explore further.
So that's why I feel that it's more than what you normally see in a collaboration. It's an integration.